are hysterectomies, yes or no. God put those parts in, seems dangerous to remove them,
if nothing is cancerous there, right? Well, there's other reasons why a person would have their
university removed into or they're overraced removed, and it's not just because of cancer. So
if a person has a fibroid tumor, for instance, very common non-cancerous condition,
but fibroid tumors can lead to morbidities that are very uncomfortable, typically lead to
anemias that are uncorrectable, and you have to have that fibroid removed, and at certain
point getting the uterus removed may be a better choice. So there's other reasons. So just to do
a hysterectomy, just because you're a beyond child buried age, and it's I just want to get my parts
removed, seems, yes, I would agree, seems odd, seems like, you know, why would you go through a
surgery that you don't need to go through? But if you're having issues, then that's another problem.
Of course, you know, in itself it caused problems. So I know beyond child buried age, and I want to
leave my ovaries, I just want to get my uterus removed, my doctor's trying to push me to do that.
Okay, uterus takes up space in the lower pelvic area. People that get the uterus removed tend to have
end up with tipped bladders, ended up with recurrent bladder infections. That's just a possible
complication to that. So there's reasons why not to do it. Second comment, come in pelvic organ
prolapse to make room. So if you're having prolapse issues, and the doctor is thinking that the
uterus is contributing to that, you got to weigh all those things out. So hard question to answer
without knowing the details of the overall condition. But in general, yeah, there's reasons to
remove an organ. There's reasons to remove your appendix. There's reasons to do a hysterectomy,
and you got to weigh out the positives and the negatives, how it's going to help the person's overall
help. If you're already in a situation where you're not going to necessarily quote, quote, use that organ
for reproductive purposes, then it's an easier decision, but you want to weigh everything out.